いやこのアイコンは本当に可愛いと思うんだ
やあー皆んなこんにちは　ハジーポッターだよ
[Hello everyone my name is Haji- potter]
皆んな久しぶり　元気にしてたかい？
[以降英語文略]
僕は体調がとーっても悪かったよ
[I'm very ｷｬｯｼｰ]
おデコのMはドMのMさ
[My Odeko
今日は僕が最近見つけた素敵な魔法を
皆んなに紹介しようか紹介しないか
とーっても迷っているところだよ
[呪文を唱えて色々な魔法で]
[お前たちぶっ殺す]
ハッハッハッハッハッハッハッハ
今日の魔法はねとってもとっても危険な魔法に見えて
とっても安全な魔法さ
僕のラーメンはいつも
こってりさ
すいません　日本語で喋ります
皆んな煙って知っているかい？
煙っていうものはこう火からおきるものなんで
ちょっとなんか危険っぽい感じがすると思うんだけども
世の中には危険じゃない煙　スモーク
なんか演出とかで使われるスモークっていうものがあるんだ
それが今日はAmazon、いや魔法学校で売っていたので買ってみたよ
はい
うわーなんかすげぇ雑だなおい
すごーい50年前のハイレモンみたいだね
というわけで今日はこれを使って
煙を出す魔法を使ってみようと思うよ
なんか調べたいんですけど多分これね日本で売ってないんだよな
これ多分日本で作られてないから説明がすこい変なんだ
説明文によると
2回無毒って書いてあるね　なんでたろう
ってか煙が健康って頭おかしいだろう
とりあえずこれを熱するとすごい煙が出るらしいから
早速やってみるよ
ただみんなこれあれです　なんかその危ないものじゃないんすけど
普通に煙なんで　もしこういうのおうちでやるときは
お父さんお母さんのお許しおもらってからおうちでやろうね
じゃーやります
健康で無毒って言われるとやっぱ大丈夫そうな気がしちゃうんです
僕はもうガンガンやっちゃいます
ボーーー
燃やします
おお
おおぉおおおおぉ
え、待って　弱いな
これちょっとして燃え続けなきゃいけないみたいなやつかね
もう1回燃やします
ボーーー
ふざけんなああああああああ
やばっ弱っ
待って一瞬すぎん煙の量が
あれ〜？
もうちょっと燃えてすぐ出なくなりました
おい、おぃほっほっほー
思ったよりちょっと魔力が弱いアイテムだったようだね
けどすごいっすね　やっぱ無害っていうだけで
全然そんなヤバイ気がしません
というわけで今上に色んな魔法使いの生徒がいるんだけど
残りを全部一気に燃やしてみようと思うよ
そうすれときっと部屋が煙だらけになって
彼らは混乱すると思うんだ
じゃあ早速上の部屋を煙だらけにしていくよ
パァイ
やふへゐ）うわ　うわうわうわうわ
やふへゐ）うーわ
たなっち）うーわ花火
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】